für viele bereiche gab es relativ klare
regeln für einen bereich eben für die
schulen gibt es das bis heute nicht
wirklich und der eindruck entsteht so
ein bisschen das feld dann doch am ende
bisschen runter liegt es auch daran dass
sehr viele der ministerpräsidenten sehr
sehr viele der entscheider und sie eben
nicht schulpflichtige kinder im moment
keine also keine schulpflichtigen kinder
haben ich weiß wie es woanders ist ich
weiß und es gibt tatsächlich zu dass bei
uns zu hause das thema schule fast
täglich besprochen wird meine frau ist
seit vielen jahren in allen bereichen
aktiv in der schule
sie berichtet wir von den gesprächen mit
den lehrerinnen lehrern aber auch von
den kindern hört man das oder den
freunden der kinder wie die jeweilige
situation an den schulen ist ich selber
beschäftige mich echt fast die ganze
zeit damit wir haben schon mehrere
schulgipfel gehabt weil mich das auch
wirklich umtreibt wie sie mir wir machen
es perfekt dass alle möglichen branchen
geld bekommen die jetzt ein auswahl ist
auch gut so muss man allerdings ein
bisschen nachbessern aber das ist auf
dem richtigen weg nur bei der schule
habe ich auch so den eindruck das ist
für viele sehr weit weg ist und deswegen
das ist für mich eines der absolut
wichtigsten themen
die jungen leute haben doch sowieso
einen schlimmen zur ein schlimmes jahr
gehabt ich denke an meine jugend was da
alles möglich war
draußen sein freizeit gestalten mit
freunden mit freunden das alles geht
jetzt nicht noch nie war eine junge
generation seit dem zweiten weltkrieg so
eingeschränkt wird und dass sie müssen
wir alles daran tun das in der schule
für die schule und für diese jungen
leute eine echte perspektive bleibt und
sie nicht hinten runterfallen